[Music]
Carrie Underwood opens up revealing her
fall a few months ago was worse than she
first shared the singer took a bad
tumble at home in November and at the
time said she had broken her wrist and
needed surgery she has not made a public
appearance since and Sunday Carrie
confessed that she also had to get
stitches to her face writing to her fans
quote I haven't been ready to talk about
it since I have still been living it and
there has been much uncertainty as to
how things will end up it's crazy how a
freak random accident can change your
life the country singer revealed part of
her surgery the night of the fall
included 40 to 50 stitches to her face
the 34 year old says she's grateful her
injuries weren't worse and for the
support of her loved ones but explained
she is quote not quite looking the same
I honestly don't know how things are
going to end up I am determined to make
2018 amazing when I am ready to get in
front of a camera I want you all to
understand why I might look a bit
different women that we can do it all
you know there's there's no reason to to
think that we can
[Music]